jean bessière bonsoir merci merci d'être
là koné seydou ba oui oui mais bien
humainement je sais pas mais j'aime
passer au net
moi je n'aime pas badie le mais je te
connais pas et humainement donc je peux
pas t'aider je peux pas dire si je
t'aime ou pas c'est la tolérance c'est
ça pourquoi ne voulez pas vous aimez pas
sur l'airé de racisme non mais moi alors
leurs racines ce qui est dans vos
chansons je le tolère pas vraiment non
quoi comment racines qu'ils aient voté
le mal à la haine anti-française la
haine entre les femmes la lettre la
haine contre les homosexuels
la détestation qui sont pas bonnes à
dire ou es ce que vous avez quelques
jours mais alors vraiment vous voulez
pas discuté avec une musulmane au vert
pourra vous y voyez vous voilà c'est ça
ça vous va ça vous va pas le front
national ça va quoi noyer plus vous
quand on est une fois on ya bien de la
vie les jo les gens qui critiquent le
rap souvent ont peur que les enfants et
la jeunesse en l'occurrence connaît déjà
voilà non mais ils ont tellement d'après
les textes au pied de la lettre
alors qu'en fait ça fait partie de la
gamme la journée un moment et écoute du
rap puis moi j'écoute du rap sauf que
moi quand j'écoute le rap de match non
mais je peux je peux parler
soit trois minutes tu m'as dit refusant
jamais décollé voilà vous viendrez mais
[Rires]
je reste
verger pour rien ou alors c'est mon gars
mais genre va vous servir à boire dans
les loges où ces gens là je vous dis je
suis désolé mais je veux pas sortir là
il m'a manqué de respect y avait des
chaussures vêtements et en plus ma pomme
attention je vous dire non mais les gens
excusez moi moi moi je suis désolé si
rick est il vrai que c'est c'est
l'invité la règle en fait c'est évident
mais quand idée qui semble pas l'avoir
voilà donc un jour en tout cas c'est
sympa je voudrais vraiment désolé tous
les téléspectateurs ça m'a permis de
voir qui est cette personne
ça lui en france tant que c'est pas vrai
il a le droit de donner son avis sur
trouve que vos critères visent à la
sorcière on peut nuire est aussi mon
gars clapper sur le rap comme ça
directement vous dites je sais pas si
j'aime donc il a le droit
l'argent il a droit beaucoup de terrain
d'expression mais chargeant pas
aujourd'hui c'est sa géographie vous
inviter les gens à un jeu direct est
vrai que voilà booba et la fièvre soit
on le dit voilà des qui veut plus
débattre je suis désolé j'en sais pas
ces derniers mois dire voilà c'est un
dernier beau sourire voilà c'est non
mais je veux dire le ça confirme ce que
je pense c'est à dire que le rap était
est un champ de haine
vous expliquez que josiane j'ai regardé
jeune qui écoutait c'est d'aimer la
musique la plus éthique de leur fille
booba bon bah c'est pas s'il ya plein de
titres
le titre qu'il a fait pour sa fille
magnifique le guet aujourd'hui si vous
voulez aujourd'hui le rap c'est tout ce
que notre société prétend vénéré
d'accord j'ai quelques questions